my warmest congratulations from Nobel
Prize tutorial the official website of
the Nobel Prize you've just been playing
wonderfully what has the music meant for
your writing the music has been so
important I think too much when you were
a youngster you thought that music
should be you proved his profession but
the poetry took over and Thomas has been
playing piano I think his old life even
strove came here he started to be a
distant piano player you haven't read
your poetry
what would you recommend that one starts
with water you say too much it's very
difficult for the writer himself
I think this small memoir could be very
good to start with oh don't you think
that your first book you seventeen poems
should work very good footage ancestors
I think how did it feel when Peter
England called you this afternoon but
the day England is a very nice man and I
think that he you had a very very fine
telephone call talk medium
you